**Susan Daniels**: Okay, welcome to day three afternoon session final segment.
**Susan Daniels**: hey we're coming in the homestretch you guys on today's on today's lecture um.
**Susan Daniels**: Let me share my screen with you all, you should be able to see i'm double checking i'm sharing.
**Susan Daniels**: thanks for the alert to the chat guys and because everyone's respecting keeping the chat to real time on things relevant to the lecture I was able to see that, thank you very much.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay i'm sorry my screen now.
**Susan Daniels**: Let me just double check that i've got an optimized for i'm.
**Susan Daniels**: Sharing video and sound great.
**Susan Daniels**: So we're good to go welcome back everyone, so we have a couple of good points were made in the chat during the break I had made a comment about.
**Susan Daniels**: praising people publicly and you know i've got some confirmation to come through, but there was some real good comments that came back by Indian Melissa.
**Susan Daniels**: And they were like no not everybody likes public praise can be very uncomfortable and the phrase emotional intelligence was raised.
**Susan Daniels**: And that that's such an excellent point you it takes emotional intelligence to praise somebody in a way that they would be most receptive to receiving it so just wanted to shout out to India, Melissa that you made excellent points.
**Susan Daniels**: So okay.
**Susan Daniels**: um now we're going to talk about after all this communication planning we've done and we understand how communication is is you know goes back and forth and considerations in the model right, then we have to.
**Susan Daniels**: figure out know who we're communication with communicating with what medium we're going to work with well now let's get a little more targeted let's talk about how do we engage our stakeholders okay um you guys should be able to hear me if you guys can hear me just okay.
**Susan Daniels**: So i'm i'm coming across.
**Susan Daniels**: Thank you for the confirmation guys.
**Susan Daniels**: Engaging stakeholders, there is a variety of tools that are involved, and I would tend to say a lot of it has to do with soft skills okay we're talking about interpersonal skills management skills, you know i'm influencing right.
**Susan Daniels**: A lot goes into being effective and influencing and engaging with your stakeholders.
**Susan Daniels**: stakeholders, by definition, impact or can be impacted by your project either way they have opinions right and we need to be.
**Susan Daniels**: cognizant as much as risks okay well there are things in the environment that can adversely and.
**Susan Daniels**: positively impact our project, so can stakeholders, they can positively champion our project and.
**Susan Daniels**: Basically, create pathways for us open doors for us get the right people in the room for us, or they can set up barriers obstacles and impediments yeah.
**Susan Daniels**: Right ever been on the receiving end of someone that is resistant to your project you don't have to answer that in the chat but i'm willing to bet a box of doughnuts that people have.
**Susan Daniels**: So let's take a look at this.
**Susan Daniels**: Stakeholders come from a variety of sources we've already covered this right that they come from a wide range of got to look far and wide on who's going to care.
**Susan Daniels**: about my project, and then you all intimately on your stakeholder register, you have to categorize much like you categorize requirements into a work breakdown structure you categorize your risks into a risk register you categorize your stakeholders right on the stakeholder register.
**Susan Daniels**: So your stakeholder register really is little more than a long table okay of any platform that you choose and you, is where you keep and collect information.
**Susan Daniels**: But each of your stakeholders needs to be assessed Okay, and what you're trying to assess them for right.
**Susan Daniels**: Is are the internal to the company external the company that's pretty simple ways to organize it Okay, but there's other things like their influence how much interest they have in things their power.
**Susan Daniels**: Is authority formal power okay through authority or do they have power with the ability to withhold resources from you that you need.
**Susan Daniels**: hey they may not have any direct authority over you don't report to this person, but they have they have power to either give okay or take away so that's a kind of power.
**Susan Daniels**: And you also need to know what kind of relationship, you have with him this this one up your upline or is this peer aren't are not so there's different things that you take an organizer stakeholder register, but what you're trying to build is your stakeholder engagement strategy.
**Susan Daniels**: So i'm going to stop and let you read this slide and then we'll talk about the bubbles.
**Susan Daniels**: So let's start here.
**Susan Daniels**: Your stakeholder register with all the different kinds of assessments that you do have your State Court of folders and how you categorize them is really just so that you could have the right.
**Susan Daniels**: response strategy for them the right communication strategy, the right arm way to keep them engaged get them in the right meetings, give them the right information keep them informed, to the extent that they are engaged and supportive of your project.
**Susan Daniels**: So that's going to take basically involving each project stakeholder based upon the way they need to be engaged what are their needs and their expectations right.
**Susan Daniels**: And being cognizant of how they can impact your project and gave an example of withholding key stakeholders or withholding key subject matter experts are giving them to you.
**Susan Daniels**: um but, ultimately, you want to create and maintain relationships with all of your stakeholders so you have a high performing team.
**Susan Daniels**: and high performing stakeholder relationships right, you have positive working relationships with your regulatory bodies, you have positive working relationships with your vendors for just a couple of examples.
**Susan Daniels**: Allow me to take you to this next slide, and this is a tool that's much like on.
**Susan Daniels**: A restart that.
**Susan Daniels**: remember how I keep saying you are neutral, you are a political, you are there to serve you help your leadership, make up on decisions through fact based information hey, but you are not trying to.
**Susan Daniels**: You don't take sides right and to the extent possible you never say anything negative you just show on an objective tool Okay, where there might be concerns.
**Susan Daniels**: Right, so this is one of those tools that help you as a project manager get the support you need with your difficult stakeholders.
**Susan Daniels**: And if you don't think you're going to have difficult stakeholders, then you've got another thing coming okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Longer you're in this profession, the higher chances you're you have of incurring are encountering difficult stakeholders So how do you deal with them when you're at this level in the company and you've got a difficult relationship going on and it's a layer two ahead of you, I am.
**Susan Daniels**: How do you get help he Well, this is the tool So the first thing you need to understand is what the see in the D stands for okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Your C stands for the current state and then D stands for the desired state you want the stakeholder to be.
**Susan Daniels**: So right now stakeholder one whoever it is currently is really unaware of your project.
**Susan Daniels**: Which is fine, because you just haven't talked to everybody, yet, by the time this first reporting cycle happens, by the way, your stakeholder engagement assessment matrix goes up as part of your regular performance cadence to just your sponsors just your sponsors.
**Susan Daniels**: And they have the most at risk of this project, not succeeding, so they are the most interested in seeing that everybody engages the way you need them engaged.
**Susan Daniels**: So you may have a reporting cycles happen before you've had a chance to onboard and engaged with all of your stakeholders so that's Okay, you can sometimes have they're unaware of your project, but once you get a chance to talk to them you expect them to be supportive.
**Susan Daniels**: But if you go in and you have someone who's neutral as in yeah they're aware, but they're not coming to your meetings, yet okay they're not responding to your emails yet okay there's sort of just they're aware.
**Susan Daniels**: they're not resisting you they're not actively working against your project they're just sort of like not engaged right there just kind of a neutral, but she need them on board it, you need them to be supportive, you need them to start.
**Susan Daniels**: Responding to emails and meetings right.
**Susan Daniels**: This would be a problem stakeholder this would be not necessarily a problem stakeholder Okay, but this one is also a problem stakeholder the current state in the desired future state are not the same you ultimately want them to be the same in the same box.
**Susan Daniels**: you've got someone who's supportive but they're not actually leading and champion Okay, in other words they're lending you the resources, you need.
**Susan Daniels**: They are you know not being resistance there they're contributing but they're not really responding to their teams need for direction.
**Susan Daniels**: or they're not attending all the meetings that you, you need them to attend, or you send them emails and they're just not responding the way you want them to.
**Susan Daniels**: they're supportive but they're not really on board and promoting and championing your project.
**Susan Daniels**: and getting their team excited about it yeah the assigned you a subject matter expert, but you know why it's only on paper.
**Susan Daniels**: The person is always being pulled away to something else that's an example supportive on paper but in reality they're not helping you lead the way and getting this done.
**Susan Daniels**: So how do you use this document okay.
**Susan Daniels**: um.
**Susan Daniels**: All your stakeholders are listed right, and then you have it, you sort it so that only your problem, children are on top early your problem stakeholders are on top, because you don't want to have your.
**Susan Daniels**: Your sponsors have to look through the entire thing right to find them find the problem you want the problem right at the top.
**Susan Daniels**: And when you submit this okay it's often in a.
**Susan Daniels**: Private environment a private setting okay it's when you have the one on ones with your stakeholder your sponsors this really shouldn't be published much okay this she's like i'm seeing in the chat this is.
**Susan Daniels**: shared and access is very limited but it's a way of saying here's my risk register let's talk about my risks, you know here's my budget my schedule let's talk about it now let's talk about my stakeholders.
**Susan Daniels**: Oh Susan I see that stakeholder number two really is neutral and you needed to be more supportive well when they see your problems that you're having.
**Susan Daniels**: you've done this in a very objective way you know laid it out you've not complained about anybody you're not finding fault with anything you've just said hey I want to have a conversation, you know clearly let's have a conversation about these three stakeholders.
**Susan Daniels**: oftentimes your sponsors, are in a better position to communicate with your difficult stakeholders than you are right, they have more authority, they have more influence they have a bigger network.
**Susan Daniels**: In the organization, then you do mean after all they won the money for the project right so they're pretty influential.
**Susan Daniels**: All you need to do is surface these concerns, and this is the tool that's used to start those conversations and get the help you need so i'm going to pause it this and i'm going to look at the chat and see what kind of things are flowing through.
**Susan Daniels**: seems like it could get messy if it fell into the wrong hands um that's why it's not parked out in a cloud somewhere it's generally probably kept on your private drive and only brought into one on one meetings right, but you still need to have it documented, so that they can your.
**Susan Daniels**: sponsors can see it readily right and you probably take it back with you, I wouldn't email it in advance, where you're right keep the distribution loose but any any stakeholder.
**Susan Daniels**: who's who might see this that they're that they're not in their desired future state and the desired state.
**Susan Daniels**: probably knows that they're probably aware that you're wanting them to be more engaged or more supportive you're probably aware you've already tried to work this yourself I.
**Susan Daniels**: But now you're servicing it in your in your engagement matrix to kind of get the attention spotlight on it for help.
**Susan Daniels**: shouldn't it be a sponsor engagement assessment matrix.
**Susan Daniels**: um and not necessarily you're taking this to your sponsors so you're not assessing your sponsor you're assessing the stakeholders that you're working with and your project.
**Susan Daniels**: And you're taking your concern to the people have the most authority and power and at most at risk for this project, which are the sponsors.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm reading jim's comment at this point.
**Susan Daniels**: This kind of document is fine, is the level and types of details that you put into the could create issues.
**Susan Daniels**: is critical to keep this focus on material needs of the project and stay away from personal information exactly you want behaviors that you're going to be talking about not personality profiles okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Susan says, you have multiple leading stakeholders and usually these are leaders over work streams okay if you've got a supportive on paper but they're not actually leading the work for the work streams that they're accountable for um they're not acting accountable.
**Susan Daniels**: they're sending responsible people but they're not being accountable for it that's what i'm talking about and, yes, you can have multiple leading stakeholders in this sense they're leading work streams.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, this i'm looking at Peters this would be helpful if someone were to step into your shoes and take all over absolutely wouldn't you want to know.
**Susan Daniels**: When you're walking into a new project and it happens all the time guys, you can get moved from one project to another and or you could be the one that has to pick up where someone else was not as effective right.
**Susan Daniels**: Sometimes people get assigned to projects and it chemistry just isn't right and they'll go Oh, this is not a good match for this project manager skills to do this kind of project.
**Susan Daniels**: let's swing Susan so this wing Susan and she's just got to pick up in the middle of the project if she has this right, and this is privately given right, to the extent possible it's really going to help Susan know where to focus.
**Susan Daniels**: It seems in it it's better for a stakeholder to be in the unaware section, instead of the resistance section if the person is going to be resistant.
**Susan Daniels**: Well resistant resistant and unaware is unaware um and remember we try to be honest and honest is honest right you if you haven't talked to them and they're on aware.
**Susan Daniels**: it's on you and you can fix that problem you just want to let them know they're not quite supportive yet they're not on board, yet the resistant is resistant okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, is there some instance where you would want to do this for the sponsors.
**Susan Daniels**: Do you mean about the sponsors, because this is done for the sponsors okay it's given to the sponsors, would there ever be a time where i'd want to do an engagement assessment.
**Susan Daniels**: about the sponsors um let's just i'm not sure I ever put it in writing, but if i'm talking to i've got two or three sponsors and one of them is not really at the desired state.
**Susan Daniels**: It wouldn't go on this document or on this tool and chances are the other sponsors already know.
**Susan Daniels**: All right, that that sponsor is not pulling their weight chances are they're already aware and it's not your place to necessarily voice a concern I let it get pretty far before I would I let it self corrective their level first, before I would start.
**Susan Daniels**: Raising it as an issue.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm john makes a good counterpoint depends on if you need resources from them um.
**Susan Daniels**: they've got they've got their reputation and their performance at risk, so they know.
**Susan Daniels**: how important this project is because they went to bat and got the money for it, so they know their performance will be assessed.
**Susan Daniels**: On the result of this project, so chances are you can get them to lean in by just simply being forthright and asking for the resources that you need they they often are.
**Susan Daniels**: On your poor sponsors will still give you the resources it's just that they sometimes don't prioritize your project, the way you needed to um they look good on paper, but sometimes they don't actually act out that they've prioritized it.
**Susan Daniels**: um yeah john I think it would be open to tell them what you need ask for those resources be forthright still approach your sponsors, even if they are slow to respond Okay, I do need to move on.
**Susan Daniels**: develop execute and validate a strategy for stakeholder engagement, the long and short of it is you need to identify all of your stakeholders as part of your plan so you know who to your planning activities, so you know how to bake them into your communication plan.
**Susan Daniels**: But once you're in the executing phase is really about keeping everyone engaged in the in the desired state that you need them in and using the engagement matrix to communicate where you may need help.
**Susan Daniels**: The next thing that we're going to jump into is we're going to jump into create project artifacts.
**Susan Daniels**: So what we need to talk about is what is an artifact okay well an artifact is things that are produced okay.
**Susan Daniels**: i'll slow down I won't talk over the slide go ahead and read the slide.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, so.
**Susan Daniels**: understand the difference between an artist, a project artifact and a project deliverable that's the point and project documents.
**Susan Daniels**: let's start with the easy one first let's start with the deliverable that is in a unique product service on process or result Okay, that is, the deliverables right the the the work packages that the nouns that your project is producing okay all those work packages.
**Susan Daniels**: Which cobbled together may ultimately produce your big today or you can have multiple deliverables that you're accountable for, but they are results okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Your project documents are things that you produce a lot as part of your project management, it is your baseline doctors your scope management all your plans and your sub plans, it is your.
**Susan Daniels**: Risk register your budget your schedule Okay, these are project documents that you produce.
**Susan Daniels**: The law are listed kind of as part of your project management process artifacts okay project teams create artifacts during the project work.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, these are about things that are happening they're not the project documents that you may have to be updated that are part of the project management plan and project implementation plan Okay, these are.
**Susan Daniels**: Formal your artifacts are like all the emails that go flying back and forth it's the agendas, to get produced for each of your meetings it's the Minutes to the meeting.
**Susan Daniels**: that's not part of your project management plan right, those are not your project documents formal and trying to come across very authoritarian and formal your project documents artifacts are things that you produce along the way.
**Susan Daniels**: And you may have some very important project artifacts like your performance reports that you produce along the way it might want to archive some of those paid on some key contracts that are put in place, those are project artifacts.
**Susan Daniels**: um some.
**Susan Daniels**: it's really things that are produced in real time to keep the project executing and moving Okay, it is not necessarily part of your project planning and it's not part of your project arm.
**Susan Daniels**: Core.
**Susan Daniels**: Let me see how to put this I it's not part of your master plan and it's not one of the formal documents that you that you see listed in the traditional project management methodology.
**Susan Daniels**: Let me see if that can read some of the questions and see if I can add greater clarity to that.
**Susan Daniels**: Our test results from the validation process consider project artifacts yes it's produced along the way it's important to know what the results are, but it is the performance reports in the performance report results Okay, those are artifacts.
**Susan Daniels**: Could a list of people you want to work with in the future, be an artifact um yeah something produced, you may want to archive that later.
**Susan Daniels**: But it's not one of your planning documents, it is not one of your formal management documents.
**Susan Daniels**: wouldn't performance reports be part of the project documents, not necessarily okay.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm your project plans are part of your project documentation your racing is a formal project document your risk register is a formal project document it's not part of a plan it's an.
**Susan Daniels**: it's the document that is an output of doing one of your project management processes performance reports are more along things that are produced unique to that project in real time.
**Susan Daniels**: So peas are.
**Susan Daniels**: Our organizational processes organizational process assets right standard off i'm looking at.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm not sure how to say your name and I don't want to insult you by really messing it up, but the question where's palm Is it safe to equate deliverable equals externally distributed to customer i'm know.
**Susan Daniels**: It may be, but that's not the only definition for deliverable remember we do projects internal to a customer and internal to the organization.
**Susan Daniels**: And we can have internal customers and external customers a deliverable is can be as small as a work package okay that can be a deliverable combining work packages together right can then be a larger deliverable but you're looking at.
**Susan Daniels**: It some of these may not make it to the customer until they're all put together right so not every deliverable is on go straight to the customer.
**Susan Daniels**: With the engagement assessment be an artifact yes okay um.
**Susan Daniels**: Because you would choose to use it right.
**Susan Daniels**: But it's not a standard document you have to use and produce an update on a regular basis, like your risk register your stakeholder register so i'm saying some things.
**Susan Daniels**: are codified are part of the standard where you would produce it and then you would interactively update it you your stakeholder stakeholder engagement matrix.
**Susan Daniels**: You would produce it, but you wouldn't necessarily updated every time someone kind of when you have a problem.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm Susan some emails maybe artifacts things that have approvals right is look at the definition project teams create artifacts during the project workflow these facilitate management of the project.
**Susan Daniels**: artifacts enable reconstruction of the history of the project and to the benefit of other projects is things that you may want to archive as well project teams create and maintain many artifacts during the life of the project, yes.
**Susan Daniels**: Looking at the.
**Susan Daniels**: Project artifact examples.
**Susan Daniels**: Again, these are expected to be produced right your acceptance criteria any assumptions in your charter that you, you create the business case must be produced, these are things that are going to be.
**Susan Daniels**: Either you know expected to be produced along the way.
**Susan Daniels**: As well as keeping track of your your arm artifacts you also have to keep track of your arm all is the specifics okay i'm seeing some flip through here.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, remember how I talked about you have your change management.
**Susan Daniels**: And there was a slide about the change management plan and the configuration management plan okay.
**Susan Daniels**: And that was all about getting ready to do the work you know preparing to do the work now we're in on the part where we're actually in the executing work trying to deliver business value well.
**Susan Daniels**: This is kind of just going deeper on that configuration management system, I introduced what the system is earlier today.
**Susan Daniels**: This is simply saying don't forget, you have to continuously update to configuration management system, you have to keep it on if there's any changes that happen.
**Susan Daniels**: it's your job to make sure that the accountable party is updating it in the system.
**Susan Daniels**: So how do you do that right if you're not if you're working at the big 50,000 foot level of your project and trying to really keep all the integration going, how do you know that all of your updates are being done in the configuration management system.
**Susan Daniels**: I generally send out regular props hi this is your courtesy reminder to please post all you know updates on your work packages that have occurred, you know changes in specifications in the configuration management system by X date.
**Susan Daniels**: And you just basically prompt them to make sure they posted their send the link.
**Susan Daniels**: And then you can ask on other parties to go back and review it and see if.
**Susan Daniels**: you've gotten the updates in that you need, but I generally just have them self police and self report and, sometimes, most of the time just prompting them to make sure they've done, it is all it takes.
**Susan Daniels**: When you have a problem it'll come to the surface, that something that updated and somebody didn't update it in the system, and you can deal with that other when it occurs it's one of those low probability kind of low impact, for the most part, so you accept that risk.
**Susan Daniels**: But you do want to make sure that when you go to close your project that your configuration management system, with all the specifications is accurate and up to date.
**Susan Daniels**: Because, ultimately, this configuration management system is handed to the end recipient if it's an internal customer okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Sometimes, for the external customer so that they know all the specifications of their system and they're keepers of it, then, if they ever wanted update to whatever product process or process that you implemented, then they know what the starting point is.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm.
**Susan Daniels**: Your configuration management system basically ensures that the product specifications are current one of the things that you need to learn how to do is.
**Susan Daniels**: understand how you do version control okay version control is every time there's an update many systems today will save the file with a change.
**Susan Daniels**: automatically renaming it for version control, but if you don't have a.
**Susan Daniels**: system or a platform that will do that for you automatically, then I strongly encourage you, as part of your initial plan for your configuration management plan the to come up with an agreement on what is going to be the naming convention for version control and police that right.
**Susan Daniels**: Anybody out there suffering from not having good control on version control of things and you've got it saved in different locations and you're passing versions back and forth through email is not centrally located.
**Susan Daniels**: om you know all my goodness, try to get away from that nightmare, the sooner, you can get it out on a cloud or a shared drive Okay, and people have access to that shared drive.
**Susan Daniels**: You want a single source of truth right you want a single source of truth of your configuration management system and have many other documents.
**Susan Daniels**: um so definitely set your naming conventions, from the beginning, if your software platform doesn't do that for you automatically.
**Susan Daniels**: The whole slide is about that i'm a little ahead of myself sorry about that um it just basically says that there are.
**Susan Daniels**: ways that automatically date and timestamp for you, who touched it last right and when they touched it and sometimes i'll even highlight.
**Susan Daniels**: By contributor who changed what I mean there are some very sophisticated tools out there now that any changes made will track exactly where Susan touched it and when she touched it last right it's really pretty cool.
**Susan Daniels**: If you're not working with that level of sophisticated software it's on you to make sure that sort of version control process is designed and bought into by your team and you're on the subject matter experts.
**Susan Daniels**: like this just simply references.
**Susan Daniels**: And i'm this is simply references it's very important that you have a plan again you're in the Managing aspect of your project okay.
**Susan Daniels**: that you have a plan in place and you're executing very good storage and access or distribution of your content to your key stakeholders.
**Susan Daniels**: figure out where you're going to store everything who gets access to those stories locations and make sure they have the administrative rights to get into it.
**Susan Daniels**: it's kind of frustrating when you've parked all this stuff out in a shared look the shareable location and you send out the link saying hey you can come pull it down when you need it, only to find that you know the administrative update access is haven't been done yet.
**Susan Daniels**: send out my monthly performance reports to pretty broad distribution list people started pinging on it, only to find.
**Susan Daniels**: yeah lazy susie didn't actually get it done she didn't actually that employee didn't actually get the work done for all of these administrative updates for each one of those folders yikes okay so just saying.
**Susan Daniels**: Have a good thing, good well developed processes for storing and distributing your your key project artifacts.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay.
**Susan Daniels**: You seeing a lot of emphasis here on G you've got to stay in control of all of your your your key project communication and.
**Susan Daniels**: Production documents right and you've got to have a way to to do it.
**Susan Daniels**: The good news is, if you work with an organization that has a PM wow.
**Susan Daniels**: That yeah a PM out.
**Susan Daniels**: And you should remember what that is, and if you don't you might be able to guess if the p stands for project and the M stands for management.
**Susan Daniels**: And O is for office, the project management office right, this is the headquarters for basically a dedicated unit in the company that administers and manages projects for the organization.
**Susan Daniels**: Most of these organizations have a pretty standard way of building like your team site your sharepoint site your on your Google, you know if you're going to share out with Google or Microsoft onedrive.
**Susan Daniels**: If they will tell you how to organize your different folders they have it, they kind of standardized it so that.
**Susan Daniels**: Anybody looking through projects because trust me directors and Vice Presidents have multiple projects in play.
**Susan Daniels**: it's very helpful if every time they look up a project they know in the upper right hand corner, is the calendar of meetings for.
**Susan Daniels**: This project right below that is the schedule versions, you know the different schedule versions below that you can find the Budgets on this side you might find all of these.
**Susan Daniels**: TEAM members, then below that you can find the risk folder I mean there may be a fairly standardized layout of how these different cloud platforms organize the information for you.
**Susan Daniels**: good thing you do not have to invent the wheel.
**Susan Daniels**: Unfortunately, not all project managers work in big sophisticated companies some start out and fairly small moderate sized companies, then it becomes your job to figure out how you're going to create some standardized approaches to your project management of the artifacts okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay um What it does is by having your kind of a standardized approach on how things are filed and how they're there on named and where they're stored it just makes it much more efficient for timely distribution and sharing of documents.
**Susan Daniels**: But we're coming in the homestretch guys who we're going to be talking about on change management and issue management for the last that we have.
**Susan Daniels**: You guys asked me earlier if we're going to talk about change management again and I said well yeah when we talk about governance, well, I was wrong, we are actually going to pick it back up again and now it's more the how to you know the true execution process.
**Susan Daniels**: So.
**Susan Daniels**: Apparently somebody's dealing with a lot of changes in their project okay so.
**Susan Daniels**: let's take a look at what can cause changes in your project well, as you can see that can be quite a few drivers of what cause changes in your project.
**Susan Daniels**: I would say, probably the biggest one the most painful one is Mr requirements right you're going down you're thinking you're executing well you're on schedule you're on budget your stakeholders are engaged, you know you're kind of rocking it and then somebody says.
**Susan Daniels**: we've got to do this before we can do that.
**Susan Daniels**: We need to make sure.
**Susan Daniels**: whole new requirement comes up.
**Susan Daniels**: Well you've got to have a way of getting more time and more money into your budget because now, you have a new requirement telus gotta go through project formal change control sometimes regulations will come out the cup they're just absolutely require you to change your plan.
**Susan Daniels**: Sometimes specification changes can have a ripple effects that then cause problems that then ultimately uncover a need for a new requirement Okay, and then just yeah this one sad.
**Susan Daniels**: The initial inaccurate estimates, this is where you need more money, this is where I need more time Okay, and you need to go before your governance to get formal change approval So what are the components of a formal change control system.
**Susan Daniels**: When you go to design and build it Okay, these are the components, you need to take into account.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay i'm just looking.
At.
**Susan Daniels**: This is kind of a flow chart of a possible change management process okay it's pretty standardized it's pretty common how this would be done okay.
**Susan Daniels**: You have your change request form which should be extensive sets which should be an extensive questionnaire.
**Susan Daniels**: What do you need why you need it right What impact does that have as far as potential schedule will need another 10 days.
**Susan Daniels**: What kind of resources are you going to need, as far as financial what kind of human resources, might be required, can you ask about communications me you ask.
**Susan Daniels**: an array of questions that looks pretty similar to your work breakdown dictionary questionnaire right.
**Susan Daniels**: Because you've got a lot of good questions in your work breakdown dictionary what risks are associated with this change what quality metrics are we going to have relative to this change see where i'm going here.
**Susan Daniels**: All the great questions that you produce for your work breakdown dictionary crosswalk nicely into rub off the title at the top call it change request form and you're pretty close to know and where to go, I want to send out for your change request form.
**Susan Daniels**: You give that change request form to the people who think the change needs to happen.
**Susan Daniels**: Once you get it back okay you love the change request hey.
**Susan Daniels**: Does it pass the filter, in other words, is it complete Okay, did they answer all the boxes.
**Susan Daniels**: Now, sometimes people will try to not.
**Susan Daniels**: Do the change request form they just want to tell you verbally what needs to happen, you know, after all, they outrank you and they just want you to do all of lifting and all the work so they'll have a conversation with you but you've got to fill out that form.
**Susan Daniels**: don't go there yeah hey.
**Susan Daniels**: advocate and stand your ground something along the lines of well clearly you feel strongly about the need for this change, and you make a very good case for it, however, I am in not in i'm not in the best position to.
**Susan Daniels**: articulate or advocate for your change it's very much I need you to complete this form, so that I can move it forward my role is to move it forward in the process.
**Susan Daniels**: Put the monkey back on their back they might make a frowny face at you, but chances are they were just trying to see if they could get you to do it.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, but if you're not in the best position to articulate or advocate for their change, but you are back to them, I look forward to getting your response on this change request oh look i'm late for a meeting.
**Susan Daniels**: But let's assume they completed they completed and they send that back and is complete right so it's not rejected.
**Susan Daniels**: If it is right, you need to know whether what they want to change if the deliverable will be affected okay.
**Susan Daniels**: If you accept the change request is there a deliverable affected, or is this just a specification change, well, I want to change the font Okay, or I want to change some.
**Susan Daniels**: detail but they're not adding a new requirement, then you send them a rejection letters you don't need to go to formal change control just talk to the person that has the.
**Susan Daniels**: authority to change that work package specifications you just send it back to talk to that party and they negotiate at that level, but if it is a new deliverable or the deliverable is directly impacted Okay, then you prepare an impact statement.
**Susan Daniels**: You prepare this impact statement based upon them answering your questionnaire right, but you as the project manager.
**Susan Daniels**: have to because your role is integration you've got the whole picture you've got the big picture of your project.
**Susan Daniels**: they're only talking about what they care about okay and they're going to tell you what they understand the impact is from their perspective, but it can be very limited, so you really are the owner of the impact statement.
**Susan Daniels**: And you kind of put forward some additional input about possible risk or implications, to the master schedule the master buzzard.
**Susan Daniels**: let's say you get this impact statement done then a couple of things can have it it's a minor impact it's a modern impact or it's a major impact right.
**Susan Daniels**: Well, this simply says if it's a minor impact and you think you can absorb it within your schedule and within your budget if you think you can absorb it then chances are you can authorize it.
**Susan Daniels**: But if it's moderate and it's going to have on upstream or downstream impacts there's other players involved okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Then you probably need to get those stakeholders to review and come to a consensus that yes, we all agree, we need to make this change, yes, we have consensus she saw it, we agree we need to change it Okay, or it could be major where we're going for significant money right.
**Susan Daniels**: Then we need to bring in the sponsors, so the change is authorized Okay, in other words, yes, it needs to be moved forward the ability to communicate the change.
**Susan Daniels**: You execute the change, and then you rebalance the project as as in you reset the budget reset the arm the schedule, if you need to.
**Susan Daniels**: Where does the change management board fit into this major impacts okay things that are going to extend your schedule okay or extend your budget.
**Susan Daniels**: That goes before the formal up basically that's when you bring in the sponsors and you bring in your governance, sometimes changes are younger their new requirements, but there are.
**Susan Daniels**: they're small enough new requirements that you guys can absorb the impact, but you don't want to just approve it on your own authority.
**Susan Daniels**: Right unless it's small enough, and you know you're on solid ground to approve most the time i'm going to bring in other stakeholders true subject matter experts to kind of get a committee approval, you know so it's not just me saying well Susan said to do it.
**Susan Daniels**: Well, I got the stakeholders in the room, and they got we ask Susan This needs to happen right.
**Susan Daniels**: But if it can be absorbed within your existing schedule and budget these teams request can be just approved in house, so to speak, we're on within the team, but if you need more budget or time that's when the formal control comes in.
**Susan Daniels**: hoc are all change request forms filter through the change Control Board, I think I just answered that question okay.
**Susan Daniels**: um.
**Susan Daniels**: Let me look at my time I do need to cover issues Okay, and then we're going to I got a couple of more things to do so on the shelf I let me try to answer that question um you know at the at the clothes okay.
**Susan Daniels**: No, this is really good question if, during a verbal conversation they communicate the desire change.
**Susan Daniels**: And you can determine at that point that the deliverable will not be affected, can you just verbally tell them that formal change request is it needed or does this all needs to be documented, it needs to be documented.
**Susan Daniels**: It absolutely needs to be documented because.
**Susan Daniels**: People you've got it you've delegated who has authority over each word package and who can approve changes so that change request has to be documented.
**Susan Daniels**: What was requested who approved it when and why okay so it's got to be documented now the formal change request document can be light, you know they don't have to go to.
**Susan Daniels**: that they have to go to the phone will change request, what kind of impact is it going to have you have to thoroughly think through.
**Susan Daniels**: don't shoot from the hip Okay, if someone wants to do it approaches you in the hallway elevator hey we want to make this change you can't say sounds good to me.
**Susan Daniels**: Tell them complete the change request form will look it over get the right people in the room, look at the impact it's probably a pretty simple discussion, but yeah send me that change request.
**Susan Daniels**: due diligence okay.
**Susan Daniels**: when in doubt write it out okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Change requests there's different kinds of change request.
**Susan Daniels**: Just letting you know that there can be several drivers and different types.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm not sure that i'm going to give you illustrations of each kind because I do want to talk about on managing project issues, but just know that not all change requests are um.
**Susan Daniels**: It can be as simple as you know, just changing the requirements to prevent a problem from happening right it's not always something's gone wrong.
**Susan Daniels**: Right sometimes you go hey if we just have this requirement we're going to prevent a problem down the road and they just put it in a change request people go yeah makes sense to add that, and you move forward if it doesn't impact the budget of the scheduled to absorb it.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, so last thing we're going to talk about today okay is issues.
**Susan Daniels**: They happen right, and they can happen for a lot of different reasons okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Please put this in your no.
**Susan Daniels**: Risks when they happen become issues, a risk that you may have identified right or not identify, but if our risk happens is becomes an issue okay risk risks are probabilities things that could happen.
**Susan Daniels**: issues are facts it's for real guys we've got to deal with this risks of probabilities hanging out there that could happen issues are when they happen and they're real and we have to deal with it understand the difference between risks and issues.
**Susan Daniels**: We can have issues, for a variety of reasons, right.
**Susan Daniels**: And this is just simply saying how risk turns into issues.
**Susan Daniels**: So when they happen hey we put them in something called an issue log you've heard me mentioned it a couple of times that we on a regular cadence update and send to our leadership our issue log.
**Susan Daniels**: And you should be very transparent and very honest about the issues your project is having i've coached you that.
**Susan Daniels**: When you walk into your reviews with your your governance they're there to help you they are there to senior project succeed, they have some vested interest.
**Susan Daniels**: In your project or they wouldn't be on your governance board they're in it to see it succeed so rock coming in with your issue log is pretty much a way of saying hey, this is what we need to talk about this time okay me here's what's going on, that I need to discuss.
**Susan Daniels**: In your issue log you're going to enter identify what the issue is when did it open right and who is the owner of this issue oftentimes it's the person who's accountable for the work package okay.
**Susan Daniels**: The person who is accountable for the work package our work packages that are at risk Okay, you have an owner of that risk.
**Susan Daniels**: owner of that issue, the person who's going to be responsible okay for getting this the resolution implemented.
**Susan Daniels**: Now, highly likely if it's a big enough issue there in the room, with you.
**Susan Daniels**: And they're they're like going yeah yeah let's let's get some guidance and resources and direction going and sort of tell me what to do right kind of their in their day.
**Susan Daniels**: Get direction on what they need to do to help them solve it, because if they could have solved it it wouldn't have the common issue for the most part they would have handled it within their own wingspan.
**Susan Daniels**: But he got to the point it's a problem and now it's an issue that we've escalated Okay, and you are going to report out on your issue log any open.
**Susan Daniels**: Issues that you're working at the top, are the new ones okay.
**Susan Daniels**: At the towards the middle, are the ones that are still open, but you got to plan for right and you kind of give a progress statement.
**Susan Daniels**: You know next step is expected close by, I need make comments about it and then at the bottom of your issue log which you may or may or may not print for every meeting is the ones that have closed Okay, once you have closed.
**Susan Daniels**: So issue resolution.
**Susan Daniels**: i'll let you read this lie and i'm going to tell you what I think is hilarious about this particular slide.
**Susan Daniels**: And then we'll have about five minutes to go through our arm our mastering questions.
**Susan Daniels**: hey okay does anybody seen something funny about this slide.
**Susan Daniels**: limit the number of open issues to a manageable number like you're in control of that okay all right great you know kind of limit the number of open issues.
**Susan Daniels**: um it's when risks manifest all right or unknown unknown risks start to just materialize and you're doing work around plans right I think that's funny um.
**Susan Daniels**: But here's their point and I it's just validation of what i'm telling you even pmi is saying best practices.
**Susan Daniels**: don't hesitate to escalate an issue to the project sponsor if it begins to have a major impact on the project if it's going to impact budget or schedule, or have her threatens to do so, you need to escalate it.
**Susan Daniels**: No sponsor wants to be surprised Okay, and if you start running over budget or you start running over schedule, they will have seen it coming.
**Susan Daniels**: They would have known from the issue log that this is something that's come on up and you're working it Okay, but maybe you know you're saying i've got things that can threaten.
**Susan Daniels**: me achieving my my baseline issue log is that early warning to them don't hesitate to escalate they don't like to be surprised.
**Susan Daniels**: right if you don't give them the issue log they're not going to have enough response time to control the situation or intervene in the situation to keep you on track and on budget.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, so now we just got a couple minutes left so hang in there with me okay and um.
**Susan Daniels**: Thanks Carl year you read my mind, I was just gonna say Carl should be sending you the link to the survey okay.
**Susan Daniels**: On the please complete it now, if you completed the survey and all of the questions on day one or day two please just jump into the survey and give us a score for today, because our.
**Susan Daniels**: Net promoter score is kind of a cumulative so we'd love to see your score if we've been able to continuously improve on so give us a score today, tomorrow and Friday for sure if that's all you do.
**Susan Daniels**: But if you haven't been in the survey yet definitely get out there and give us your on your feedback and your comments very valuable which of the following is not a component of the communication plan okay i'm seeing almost consistently i'm kind of a.
**Susan Daniels**: The one that is not see the word not don't read too fast right.
**Susan Daniels**: The stakeholder register in the collection of transfer of institutional knowledge i'm seeing kind of a balance coming through between B and C, so the question is, are there any we could eliminate.
**Susan Daniels**: Which is not a communication plan well.
**Susan Daniels**: We certainly need are initiators and receivers of the project information right because that's our inputs into our communication plan, we need the stakeholder register because that's kind of the beginning of who we need to talk to.
**Susan Daniels**: So we need these to the collection and transfer of institutional knowledge wow that may be part of our communication plan the frequency of these communication some cheese seems like the case could be made for all of them right.
**Susan Daniels**: But.
**Susan Daniels**: The stakeholder register itself is a different document from our communication management plan we use it to help build our our communication plan, but it's not an actual component of it.
**Susan Daniels**: dang right sorry Lisa right we use it, but it's not an actual component.
**Susan Daniels**: Which of these is a risk.
**Susan Daniels**: Oh, which of these is a risk.
**Susan Daniels**: Before you answer for sure remember risk is a probability.
**Susan Daniels**: issues are a fact so look at the language again and see which one is written talking fact based language in which one is written as if it's looming or as a potential reality.
**Susan Daniels**: There we go right so.
**Susan Daniels**: This one is the risk.
**Susan Daniels**: Which of the following is a good example of mitigating the probability of the risk of becoming overcome with smoke on a project which is the fall which of the five is a good example of mitigating our probability of a risk.
**Susan Daniels**: And so, mitigating means to minimize either the impact or minimize even the possibility, so when you're mitigating is there anything that's going to lower the possibility of this this risk manifesting.
and
**Susan Daniels**: According to pmi who wrote these questions, installing smoke detectors will minimize the possibility of there being overcome with smoke.
**Susan Daniels**: installing fireproof components, is a good idea, but that's not dealing with smoke overcoming smoke that's more like fire okay that's a different problem that you're probably solving they're saying this is the right answer.
**Susan Daniels**: So I just want to thank you once again for your engagement all day it's been on you've been great you guys have just been great engaging and i'm dialoguing with me.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, thank you very much hey I do appreciate that, thank you, but i'd i'd like to kind of stop that so that the link will stay on the screen so.
**Susan Daniels**: um please kind of stop the contributions I do appreciate thank is the don't add any more, so that that link can be captured.
**Susan Daniels**: And you all can go in there and least give us a score for today and help us on have an understanding of how we're performing, let us know if this control of the chat has really.
**Susan Daniels**: Improved your impression from your original number, and if you have any positive feedback for me i'd love to have it any shout outs to our mentors carl's been in the lead today give him a shout out.
**Susan Daniels**: And, otherwise I see you tomorrow, but please um let's keep the chat to just keep the arm the link out there for you love you guys see in the morning well my morning don't know what time it is in your part of the world, but see you soon.